greetings from podcastville you
[__]
it's wednesday march 31st
listen [__] where the hell did the
year go it was just [__] new year's
eve
and we were jumping up and down anyway
the joint
is welcoming blue box to the podcast
this is a great new sponsor
blue blocks makes the best sleep mass
known to mankind
let me explain something ever since i
moved to jersey i had to switch my time
zones
a couple of years ago i read a book uh
rogan had a guy on there
talking about a book about sleep the
book was [__] tremendous i cannot
find it
i don't know what the hell happened to i
think i lent it out sleep is [__]
important
it's important is it i can tell when i
gain weight it's because i'm not
sleeping a full late hours
blue block sent me this mask about three
weeks ago they sent me three of them
my daughter uses it my wife uses it and
i use one
and i'll tell you what it's tremendous
why because any amount of light can keep
you awake
but the blue block sleep mass it blacks
out everything
total darkness once you go black
you'll never sleep with anything else
again it cups your eyes and it makes
your world go away
and it helps you drift off to sleep
seriously you need darkness around you
when you're sleeping
if you work nights take the butcher
paper off the window
if you're a crackhead get the aluminum
foil on the off the window
and get this proven to increase rem
and deep sleep the adjustable head strap
doesn't wear out
and it's control sides allowed for you
side and belly sleepers
there's no slipping i mean i wear it
over my sleep apnea mask
it's comfortable and it doesn't squeeze
your face like a grape
plus it's made with lightweight
breathable fabric
to keep you cool all night long i mean
these guys thought about everything you
understand me so do me a favor
support blue blocks because they support
the joint get yours today
sleeping is one part of health that not
a lot of people take seriously
i didn't for a long time and now this is
why i'm looking the way i'm looking
because i'm sleeping so do me a favor go
right now to blueblocks.com joey again
that's bluebox.com joey
get 20 off when you press in so go to
blue block
blue blocks dot com b l
u b l o x dot com
slash joey and use promo code joey for
off night night [__] you're gonna
hit me up and go joey
i'm sleeping like a doctor because of
you thank you
you're welcome anyway the joint is also
brought to you by
zip recruiter are you hiring right now
this is the time of the year when things
start to open up
the vaccine is rolling out what kind of
piece of people are you looking for
do you need somebody to wear a lot of
hats what do you need
finding that person is hard it's like
trying to find a needle in the haystack
that's where zip recruiter comes in you
find quality candidates
fast and i'm going to give it to you for
free you can try it for free
at ziprecruiter.com joey
whether you need to hire a cook in
calabasas a nurse in the
nebraska or an attorney in arkansas
they got you zip recruiters matching
technology hooks you up
with people who have the skills and
experience that you need
and then it actively invites them to
apply for a job
so get the qualified candidates fast
from accounting to zoologists and
everything in between
zoop zip recruiter will make hiring that
much easier and right now
just for the joint family you can try
ziprecruiter for free
joy what are you talking about free free
free
f-r-e-e by going to ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com you
get to try it for free
i get credit for sending you there so
once again try it for free
whether you got a small business or you
got 10 000 employees zip recruiter is
the way to go
it saves you time energy and effort
and you get to try it for free just by
going to ziprecruiter.com
joey ziprecruiter the smart way to hire
let's get this party started it's
wednesday it's the last day of the month
and we got a lot to talk about
hey how
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
where you been it's a beautiful
wednesday
morning it's the last day of the month
we [__] did it listen
i don't know about you it was just
[__] new year's eve it was just
december 31st
you were running to your buddy's house
you had to park around the corner
so the cops don't know you're at the
friend's house they couldn't have more
than eight people
and look at us now we're ending [__]
march 31st
we're rolling into [__] april and
we're rocking and rolling we got a new
look everybody's happy
everybody's having a good [__] time i
had a weird
week let me tell you what's going on my
daughter listen
let me talk to you people about
something from the heart my
i never sat down and watched nothing a
couple years ago i went over to a
friend's house
well not my friend it's my father-in-law
and he was watching girls softball
he's 70 years old i'm like this is the
creepiest [__] thing in the world
you're watching girls softball
who watches [__] girl softball i got
nothing against girls and i got nothing
to get softball
but when you're a guy my age you just
don't watch girls softball you know what
i'm saying i mean you're like what the
[__] is this
so now my daughter gets into softball
right
so i'm like you know i got to sit there
during the practices
and i'm sitting there looking i feel
like johnny pedophile it's all a bunch
of moms
and it's me and a [__] on the
bleacher by myself
you know all i need is a rainjack and
the cop will pull over
and i feel like that so the first week i
felt like [__] i'm like i can't i gotta
figure something out because
i never really watched and in 2006
when i was still doing coke i went to
see my niece play my nieces was a great
great basketball player
and i went to see her playing tennessee
and i had and it was a girl's high
school game
and i had a good time but i really
didn't think about it but now with all
the [__] that's going on you know
you feel [__] guilty watching
anything you know so i'm watching this
last week i'm watching this the girls
practice they're all eight years old and
i'm like
look at the mom still looking even
though i'm sitting there my wife is next
to me i'm like
they're looking at me like i'm a [__]
pedophile and [__] watching girls
[__] softball
i left there walking like [__] any
minute now the cops are gonna put the
handcuffs on me
then i went to the second practice and
there was another dad there
so i didn't feel that bad but again i
felt a little creepy
but then i'm a 60 minute guy so i
watched 16 minutes on sunday night
and if you want 16 minutes it was about
an old guy that [__] was in the
writers hall of fame
this guy wrote a book about muhammad ali
he [__] interviewed muhammad ali i
don't know how many [__] times he
wrote
he wrote a book about his relationship
with ali and cosell
he's just a great writer wrote articles
of sports illustrated a couple weeks ago
when tiger woods got into the accent
they ran out to him for him to write the
article
and when as he got older and got into
retirement
he started going i guess his
granddaughter or somebody played for
basketball girls basketball
so he started going all these girls
basketball games and he said
what am i doing myself i should start
writing about him
so he created like a column about the
girls basketball team and what they were
going through
just to give the girls light and whatnot
and i'll tell you when i watched that
it made me feel a little bit better like
i'm like all right i'm not a [__]
pedophile
sitting over here watching these [__]
girls [__]
do their thing so no bubbles
yeah so now i feel a lot more [__]
comfortable
you know at the games and uh well they
haven't played yet but they're still
like in practice to have for clinic
today
they got a clinic tomorrow which i'm
gonna go to today i can go obviously i'm
here with you [__] suckers
but uh thank you very much for sticking
it out with me
over the last couple months i have a
great habit god bless me with something
good i like to
checking with my friends i love to check
in with them and see how they're doing
and especially during this pandemic what
i did was i made a list of my single
friends and i would call them first
to let them know i had their back and
then i would call my married friends but
i would call my comic friends and just
to see how they were doing
you know i'm married i have a support
system here i have
great friends i have great uh family
members in jersey
a lot of guys stayed in l.a a lot of
guys moved
and i know the guys that moved are
confused as much as i am you know
they're getting adjusted to new areas
but it was funny while i was talking to
these guys on the phone
i was going these [__] phone calls
a podcast these are podcasts these are
this isn't we're not promoting an album
we're not promoting a cd
we're not promoting dates we're just
having phone calls about our deepest
most intimate [__] things here like
what we're going through
this is a podcast so this is why i
started reaching out to all my comedy
buddies
just to check in i'm happy you guys are
enjoying it and i'm happy you guys are
feeling it
because you could feel that we actually
missed each other like these guys and i
were tight we were all tight at one time
we'd see each other once or twice a week
we would give advice to each other on
different comedy clubs or whatever
and then one day the carpet got pulled
from us so
i figured these conversations that i
have on the phone
could be great podcasts and that's where
zoom came
in and i'm happy you guys are enjoying
it
and uh the zooms are so special like
i i hate to explain this to people and i
hate
coming off like this but if you're not
if you don't have a prior relationship
with somebody
i feel the zooms don't come off right
and i've done four zooms
since i've been here and three out of
four of them
were shitty and one person i actually
knew
the other two podcasts i did i kind of
knew the people
but not really and the zoom didn't work
with the zooms i'm giving you it's
people that i actually love
and i have a relationship with and
that's why they seem to work and i
haven't seen them
so you're listening to not an interview
like in a regular podcast
you're listening to a extended phone
call
of two old friends not uh seeing each
other for seven months
today we have another extended phone
call he's a dear friend of mine i met
him
when i got off the plane in la when he
he was at his hottest as an actor
and his mom introduced him to me at the
improv
and i never forgot how much of a
gentleman
he was to me at that time and then years
later we reconnected through stand up
and we became friends and uh
i love him to death as crazy as he is
ladies and gentlemen i bring you
michael rappaport enjoy [__]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
are we rolling joey
we're rolling jack what's happening
everything is good hold on i want to
make sure everything is good
i got the good mic out for you joe i'm
not playing games here with these
[__] guys
good good good i'm happy great to see
you good to see you
god bless you what is happening [__] man
i mean there's a lot in nothing um i'm
in los angeles
i'll give you a joey coco diaz exclusive
because i haven't i haven't said this
publicly but i'm actually moving back to
new york
uh in may um i've always had a place in
new york i've kept a place in new york
through my bi-coastalness but it
more so than moving back to new york um
i i don't have a place in los angeles
for the first time since
you know my 325 apartment which then i
moved into when i started doing the
movie true romance
because i thought i was a a a rich i
moved into an 850
a month apartment and then you know then
you know
progressively you know moved up but
when i came to los angeles in 1989 i was
19 i was living in this
apartment did you ever live in the
apartment or hear about the
the comedian's apartment over there on
carlton away in hollywood
no it was it was it was a trip because i
mean i was
literally 19 years old you think about
how [__] stupid you are when you were
19 but i lived in this 325 dollar
a month studio apartment it was nice it
was clean the building was clean but you
know
it was a [__] up neighborhood over
there on carlton way
off a gower right in hollywood and a
bunch of comedians lived there a bunch
of
different comedians came in and out of
there throughout the years
and um but yeah i'm uh i'm uh
i'm uh i you know given up my career
here in l.a
i'll be you know for the first time not
have any crib in in uh
in los angeles you know and uh you know
and i'll be in new york i don't know
what i'm gonna do i might wind up
getting another place here i might wind
up getting a place out by you i might
become your neighbor
but i'm excited about it and you know to
be honest with you
when you called me um i can't remember
when but it was you know in the [__]
pandemic
and i was talking to you and you were
like i moved i moved to jersey i think i
had heard it but i don't think
i was sure because you know you start
hearing this one's moving that one's
moving around stuff
but i was like you know that
conversation definitely was you know we
were already sort of set to do it but
when you told me i'm out i'm in [__]
jersey i was like
i had told my wife and she was like [__]
joey left and i was like yeah [__]
coco diaz went back [__] new jersey
so you know uh you know a lot of people
that come to la they go i hate l.a i
don't hate
la i like a lot of things about la
and like i said i'm an actor there's
always going to be
part of the [__] year where i'm out
here um
doing something and and you know uh i
wouldn't be mad if i came back out here
you know for work or whatever but for
right now i'm just not happy where i
live in l.a
and you know and we've been wanting to
move you know full-time
uh to new york and you know when we go
to new york we've been trying to do it
for the last two years but just
you have to do it to do it so we're kind
of doing it backwards
but i'm excited about it
you sell the house already done
how fast less
less than 24 hours how [__] crazy is
that yo
how crazy is that we said we were gonna
sell the house
we had the [__] photographer come
over the guy with the drone come over
the next morning before it was listed
the broker told another broker you know
they all know each other they said we
want to have somebody come over at 10 am
i was like tinny
all right fine they said all right you
know they'll be over for a half hour
these [__]
were there for two hours which means
they're
somewhat interested i mean it's it's a
[__] house two hours it's not like i
live on some
palatial estate with you know mountains
and [__]
they said they're interested they said
can they come back at three o'clock
i said all right they come back at
[__] three o'clock
you know they better be doing something
they said no they're they're really
interested they came back at three
o'clock
you know they said uh it's going to be
an hour i i call them i said they done
they go no they're still here so me and
my wife are driving around you can't go
to eat so we could we normally would go
to eat this was like when [__] was
closed
i call the guy yo can we come back cause
can you give us another half we're
driving around [__] laurel canyon we
go up to lookout mountain we're trying
to make out with my wife in the hills up
there
two and a half hours we come back they
go they're really interested
listen these [__] displaced me
for six [__] hours
in one day they better [__] do
something they made an offer before the
house went on
the market boom i was shocked [__] yeah
that's how fast it's going
so the the the the photos and the
[__]
the drone [__] it was i mean it went
that quick
and then you're like oh [__] you have
that moment where like oh
[__] do it you know and the offer was
great and the money was great and it was
the first person
and and you know and boom we're we're
done
we're getting the [__] out of here and
and i'm excited about it and like i said
i'm not one of these new yorkers who's
like l.a sucks anybody from new york
jersey how could you think la sucks you
might think the people sucks the weather
is ridiculous
you know the beach is great there's
great food i mean there's a lot of
things that
suck about la and to be honest with you
since those [__] riots
uh last year melrose
santa monica sunset beverly
third all of in the area in the laugh
factory improv area i guess that's
la hollywoodish it's a it's like a
[__] bomb went off
it's starting to get a little better but
that
um you know uh uh my area
not my actuals my area and you know
we've had homeless [__]
no disrespect but you know i had
homeless [__]
across the street from my house and and
they were harassing neighbors
and one of these [__]
was was there was a neighbor from around
the corner they got into a little
argument or something
one of these [__] joey this woman
she pulled her pants down and shat in
her hands and
threw it at my neighbor i said if that
had been my [__] wife and this animal
threw [__] at my wife
so i took all their because what they've
been doing in los angeles and listen
people are this that whatever
what they've been doing is they know the
rules and all that stuff so the next day
i took because so they were they were in
a place where the cops couldn't tell
them to move because they know how to
park their [__] on the street and and
and i i
i i took their [__] i took a [__]
stick i took all this [__] after they
they threw the woman [__] in her hands
and threw [__] at the neighbor
i took all that their [__] i threw it in
the [__] street
then i called the cops because they were
blocking traffic these [__] are
blocking traffic
and they got the [__] out of there but
when when you throw
[__] at people it's time to go
you can't be throwing human [__] at
people joe
i don't know what happened and uh you
just blew me away
you're a you're the last of the real new
yorkers
and you saw it you saw what i saw like i
just saw something that
was not beautiful anymore it was gonna
be
problematic somewhere along the line i'm
too old
to be carrying a [__] gun right you
know i'm too old that
my charles bronson days are over with
you right
uh it was just a scary place
right you know the kids you have grown
up kids your kids are grown in college
i have an eight-year-old the park is
bombarded with homeless
and again you know it's mental health
and whatnot
but it was just time to go i had done my
23 years you've been there
10 years longer than me you're there 30
something years
you know you did everything you could
there now
and now it's time to move back to
[__] new york and it's you and your
wife moving to new york
me and my wife my kids are one of my
kids is actually in new york
college the other one's here
but yeah i mean you know i'm getting the
[__] out of here
i'm excited about you know my kids are
fine they love new york they come back
and forth that's
you know and they're older so they
travel by themselves
hopefully you know they could continue
uh you know
you know with the health and all that
[__] but yeah they we're getting the
[__] out of here you know
and i'm excited about it you know it's
like you know we talk about
changing and packing i'm sure you went
through it you know
the [__] packing and the moving and
the boxing
there's a great thing about moving when
you're done with it because
one thing that i've we haven't even
officially moved yet
but getting rid of the amount of [__] oh
my god
are you are you are you like have you
you must accumulated
all sorts of [__] you have no [__]
idea
and you have to make the hard decisions
and go do i need this [__] it's gonna
go
picture do i need every goddamn [__]
photo every goddamn book every
tchotchke every piece of [__] every
chord every [__]
wire i haven't worn this sweatshirt in
a year oh i like it bye i've been at i
was just at the uh
when i hit you this morning i was at the
goodwill
they know my [__] name there it's
like cheers for me in the last month
i'm like [__] i'm like woody
harrelson and when i left the goodwill
was closed
what'd you do with all your [__] i just
dropped it off in front of goodwill
oh right i kept dropping off bags i took
the books to a [__]
place by my daughter's school they had a
school thing
i put books in there and growing weed i
put
books of [__] uh russian rules of
life
there was books that i had that i had
read
15 [__] years ago why did we keep
this [__]
because it's not that i'm not a hoarder
by no means trust me i'm telling you
you put stuff away and you you know you
get off the
you go then you become a comedian and
then you
do a podcast and you get things sent to
you by sponsors
people who think they're going to come
on the show and then they look at your
show and they'll
you know i threw away there was two
closets michael rappaport
you could not believe what was in there
i mean from [__] guitar speakers
to [__] micro wallets how many
[__] speakers does one person need
how
god mini speakers midsize speakers god i
had [__] pictures
you know people on the road are very
generous i love them to death
i find i found something that has to be
a collector's item
that's got to be worth thousands
somebody gave me a honeymooners dish
uh the honeymoon is a ralph with the
sweat around dancing the huckleberry
i just found that last week i gotta
bring it down here
you know you find [__] that you don't
even remember you
have we threw away boxes
boxes of stuff it's good it's liberating
and it gives me a lesson going forward
i'm not keeping any [__]
no now people are like do you have a p.o
box no
i have nothing don't send me anything i
appreciate anything because i've got a
shed out there still
loan me a kiss i don't need it if you're
gonna send me another black t-shirt
don't send it please i don't want your
[__] black t-shirt
oh my god i don't want your [__]
you're starting an underwear line
you got boxer shorts with a picture of
bugs bunny or
[__] donald duck or me or you i don't
want any of it i don't want the boxes
i don't want your [__] scented
candles that are organic
that comes from the the honey of a bee
that you
i don't want any of this [__] [__] i
don't want your experimental toothpaste
i mean no no it was it was ridiculous
what i had in that clock i had
a company started sending me jiu jitsu
because i'm a fat [__] and they were for
oversized fat [__]
they would send me two gigs a week why i
had i only went to jiu jitsu twice a
week
and i had 30 [__] e's well for what
from this company one company was great
this
what do they think that you or any
person wants that many keys for
i had to go to three different jiu jitsu
school and go here you go
next time a fat [__] joins up don't
charge them first and even then they
didn't want all the [__] geese they
were like what are we gonna do with this
i had [__] those things those
sweatshirts that you wear underneath
i had [__] stuff vitamins minerals
cbd oils i had rocks i
had it was like no that's it and it was
just
we couldn't get a dumpster no nothing
when we left in august i couldn't get
anything
we found out we found out july 12th
we found out this is this was our
journey
we found out july 12th that there was no
school
i told my wife let's make a move
i we called a person he said he could
probably help us he didn't know
i called jimmy florentine he hooked me
up with his sister-in-law
we put an offer in on one house it went
we saw this house and right away we
wrote her a letter
we seen the inside i sent my brother
down here
oh wait you you you you sent your
brother you didn't physically see it
yourself
no wow i said but you had somebody check
it and you saw the
my brother's a house inspector up north
that's right so he he
he said this is what it's like and he's
showing you pictures and all that came
down here with a [__] zoom
we zoomed everything he inspected the
gates the dirt the trees
everything he goes go we put an offer in
we wrote her a letter
and i knew when my wife [__] walked
in the door
just the look on her face i knew we had
the house
dope we probably had the house 10 days
later and we started throwing [__] out
[__] right away and it was
mind-boggling
yeah it's good but the thing was like a
lot of people don't know this
when i came back to shoot the sopranos i
made up my mind that i was moving back
it was when i was gonna pull the trigger
i knew she wasn't gonna start the second
grade in california
right kovitz just helped the process
move along
right and that was the truth i was
moving all along i knew
when after i came back here to shoot
that movie and i spent three weeks
i said to myself what the [__] am i
doing i'm out there alone
i have no family out here we spend
christmases alone we spend new years
alone you know i'm working with comics
i want a normal life i just want to live
in a community where i could drive and
get a [__] salami sandwich and
people don't talk about instagram all
day and
you know how many [__] uh can you
come on my party it was just
it was so overwhelming and i didn't know
it till i got off the [__] plane and
i landed here
are you so you love your house
and you've been there like [__] what
nine months
i've been here it'll be officially eight
months
april 19th so how do you feel being back
in jersey like
you know with a dope crib that you're
happy with
you know like how does it feel at this
point in your life being back
what part of jersey can you say what
part of jersey south jersey
south jersey 50 minutes away from new
york city
so how does it get to so how does it
feel so far
it took me about two months to realize
what i had done
this has been like in layers like it
it's been like really a mental [__] in a
way it's been like layers like
it was two months of greatness then it
was two months of doubt
you have doubt did i make the right
mistake did i make a mistake you know
for me it was about my daughter and my
wife oh you made the right decision for
them
yeah it wasn't a comedy career no for
no because for them it's great listen
they're out right now
my daughter and my wife are out right
now with three other moms
they're at a [__] rock climbing place
you know friday they went to long branch
just to get pizza and they went you know
they got a group of moms here they give
a [__] you know they tried closing the
schools here
good luck these [__] parents said
everything they could to those [__]
board of education people
i mean i listened to the zoom and i
couldn't believe what they were saying
were they going off going off you're not
going to keep these [__] pants
where i live it's 74 of people
in this town have two kids under 18
living in their house
so it's a very family oriented community
my wife said when you have to hear the
zoom meeting
they went after the superintendent of
schools they were like [__] you
were they calling them a [__] oh
my god they were like you're just
worried about your contract
if this continues we'll we'll veto it
we'll shut you down
we'll shut you down you miserable moment
in l.a the parents didn't do dick
like it was like they accepted it like
that's it we're gonna just lay down
over here these [__] parents oh my
god every [__] day they're sending
emails
they call my wife to send an email
they got the principal the vice
principal the state
all this area down south jersey the
schools are wide open wide open five
days a week
four days a week one day virtual it's up
north
where it's everything's still shut my
hometown they're not even thinking about
going back to school they might go back
towards the end of [__] april there's
gonna be some dumb [__] kids joey
let me tell you something these these
[__] there's kids that last year that
got passed
that you know shouldn't have passed
there's kids that are graduating that
are
two [__] two two like a year and a half
i mean i i think about like you know i
see these these these things on
zoom classes if i was a student
on zoom first of all they'd kick me
they'd be like
you're not i after two days they'd be
like where
you got to do something they kicked me
out but i would run these [__]
teachers into the ground
in in the way i was the [__]
disruptive
[__] pain in the ass i would be i'd
make these
miserable [__] teachers if i was a
student i'd have them
they wouldn't sleep if they had me
during a pandemic as a kid i was a
[__] pain in the [__] ass uh
uh but i didn't want to be there anyway
is zoom class
come on man they're passing [__]
people that have no business being
passed because what are they gonna do
leave behind 12 kids like
c and d students they're like just just
i don't want to deal with them again
because if you hold them back you got to
deal with these little [__]
so it's it's good it's going to be it's
going to be a fallout from this [__] in
10 years
and then in 10 years these kids are like
well the trauma from the pandemic
because i had to take zoom class and it
was so traumatic
the [__] out of here with that [__]
oh aaa meetings are going to be packed
with these zoom kids
these [__] zoomers are going to be in
their [__] zoom generation
i drink because of zoom you know [__]
i can't see a zoom
nothing his last name starts with a z so
i get flat
i relapsed the zoom generation let me
tell you something i saw what was
happening to my daughter
i'm not a [__] scholar i'm not a
psychiatrist
the parents weren't you know we were at
the beginning of the pandemic and nobody
knew what to
think and there was a certain fear
they told you kids won't have it let's
meet at the park we'll social
distance let the kids play with mask on
you couldn't get parents to do that and
i could see my little girl going
backwards
and when we got here and we started they
told us that
she was having a little problem and then
they went
back on thanksgiving you know school
started here september 4th like nothing
happened
right and then in november is when they
shut us down
a teacher got it and these [__]
parents went to work
jack they were like [__] you we'll put
them in a [__]
catholic school because catholic schools
are wide open see covert don't attack
catholic people
why not i don't know the catholic
schools are wide open they got no mask
on
nuns they're [__] shaking their
titties everything's fine in the
catholic schools
the public schools are [__] locked
the [__] down
so how can you know christian brothers i
think is closed down a couple schools
but
the trauma that's going to be done to
those california kids and kids across
the country
one year of no social activity [__] up
here i send my door if it's sunny you
better get the [__] out of this house
and talk to kids there's a guy across
the street from staten island
he's got two kids i got the hindus next
door
i got the cop son down the corner the
hindus don't go out it hit
india so hard oh that the indian kids in
the area
and the asian kids do not go to school
here wow
i mean these kids do not even leave
their house my friends they don't [__]
around huh no my friend has an indian
family next to him
he says i guess who i saw the other day
the indians finally came out they hadn't
seen him since november
because it hit india so hard that they
got news over here
how bad it was and they're [__]
petrified
are you are you um have you been doing
comedy yet have you started doing it
like what's your deal with doing comedy
doing shows and moving around are you
doing local [__] what are you doing here
it is
first of all i have guilt i have guilt
that
if i do a 300 seat show and somebody
brings it home
i got to live with their [__]
grandmother's death or grandmother
getting sick of my death
number two i gotta be honest with you
michael rappaport
you saw what was going on at the store
you saw we were living his comics
i had been doing it since that like that
steady since 2010 oh
it's time for a [__] breather you
need a break
everybody needed a break good we were
all caught on the ferris wheel
what's netflix gonna do what netflix
isn't going to do show time
you got to get that thursday they added
an extra show
i mean listen we did things that i'm
very proud of
but we i think a lot of people step back
now and go hmm
i think we were going a little bit too
hard
for me to answer your question i had
been doing stand up
to about 10 days ago and there was a
situ
i do it at uncle vinnie's down in point
pleasant yeah yeah [__] great club
dino's a great guy if you're ever in the
area
call them up and do the weekend it's an
easy weekend
the problem i had was the one week a
customer went in there
and had covert so they closed it down
they were panicked
and then another week and then
i just put it in god's hands i know i
had knee research i
i got a new knee uh january 8th i got a
news like bionic knee
yeah like i got a [__] whole new knee
like i got a whole new room
went and did it i couldn't do it in the
[__] pain no more
and uh i don't know where the [__] we
were going with this knife
no you were saying about the shows about
uh about the shows
i did the surgery january 8th i worked
hard
rap aboard i got off the pain pills i
went to pt
i [__] started lifting in mid
february i started walking without the
thing i did everything perfect
no problems at all the knee came along
fine
and all of a sudden about 10 days ago
i'm getting the swelling on the side of
my knee
i don't know what it is it's not my knee
it's something on the side
and when i went for my checkup i kept
calling the doctor going i need
muscle relaxers i'm getting like a big
lump on this side and he must relax
[__] guy wouldn't give him to me like
i'm gonna snort muscle relaxes or some
[__] i could see if i was accident
actually axing him for oxycodone or pain
pills i was just asking them for like
muscle relaxers understand that's like a
a 1200
milligram [__] a leave one of those
uh
uh-huh oh yeah the higher the higher
aspirin
he wouldn't [__] give him to me so he
goes no come back for an appointment i
went down they did an x-ray
and then the chick said no there is
something wrong let me do an x-ray from
a different angle
and they found that the the i.t muscle
something had like a little tearing or
whatever so they just oh [__]
but you know what i'm walking all right
i'm fine
what i'm gonna do is this i got sick and
tired i've taken covert test
every other [__] week three tests you
gotta take the rapid
the [__] one and then one five days
later yeah i'm done the other night i
stayed up
and i put my name on 20 lists for the
johnson johnson
so i'm just waiting for the call he just
announced 55 or over
new jersey you're allowed so i put in
for johnson and john
why johnson the one shot yeah i'm scared
of [__] needles so
are you yeah big time big time my
favorite you go
take a little poke one poke you'll be
fine he'll give you a little
in the ass i i don't have a problem with
needles last time i got a needle in the
ass i fainted at the [__] table one
of those [__] stupid [__] shots
when i give blood i i get dizzy and my
palms start sweating like
really yeah mental right yeah it's all
mental i do not like it you could tell
if i'm going for a needle if i tell you
as soon as they call me and go you have
a shot next tuesday at 12 45
come over here on monday and watch me
all day i'm a bumbling stumbling [__]
jerk off
i bump into things i'm scared excessive
pissing
you know it just [__] with my insides i
just don't like needles
i'm gonna do this because
i want to do comedy eventually i wanted
to go back into big rooms and do comedy
you know
i don't want to get covered because i
performed for 41 [__] people
if i'm going to perform let's [__]
perform right right
[__] people right so let me do this
let me take some time off i just got
back to jersey
right it's been 30 years since i've been
down to jersey shore
right i signed her up for camp i'm going
to go run different [__] shores every
week
and explore i'm 58 years old
and i did a complete [__] circle and
i'm back here
i left here a [__] pit bit thief
i left here a two-bit [__] thief you
know homeless
the only option i had when i left here
was prison i ended up in prison
i turned my life around i moved to l.a
things happened the way they did
i don't control them and at one point i
was like i think i sho after i shot the
netflix special
i was done in 2016. i was like
what is this all about it's time and
then i got the soprano movie and i got
to spend three weeks here
when the [__] is that thing coming out
september 24th
they had to i'm not mad at them you
cannot be you're in the movie business
there's a big investment
yes you got to get your money back the
movies they did release green anyway it
doesn't change it's not like it's
so what we're gonna do is this we're
gonna [__] you figure by
july first you know 50 of us will be
vaccinated
the other half so hopefully i think by
july
august we open up movie theaters right
and we could all see movies the way
they're supposed to be seen right
you know i saw the new jared leto movie
with denzel
washington yeah i thought it was men's
and mort on tv
because i watched it on tv yeah yeah
yeah the effect of a movie theater is
[__] huge on him
yeah people have no idea i i know the
difference when i watch a movie at home
when i watch a movie in a movie theater
when i watch a movie on a plane
yeah it's different when i watch a movie
at home you're in no danger
i'm looking at the wall i'm looking at
my toes
i'm sniffing my armpits i'm scratching
my nuts
when i'm at the movie theater i'm there
you know you're there
you're feeling it you yeah you're right
so i think they were going to release it
march 14th
i think david chase said what am i going
to do if i want to release it at home
i worked hard on this let them wait
nobody's i'm not pissed
meaning i want people to watch the [__]
the right way yeah
it's like you're lined up i want people
to be in a room
that they're happy to be in yeah you
know i'm not [__] scared to death
let me have you done any of these you
know it's been good in los
angeles i'll tell you one thing that's
been [__] great
these little mini outdoor shows they're
tremendous
and they're tremendous here thank god
when i got here they were just
perfecting them
now they got it down now they really got
it down and they're going to just do
outdoor venues
tons of them here yeah like i said mike
i want to give this a breather
i want to fall in love with comedy again
all over again i want to fall in love
with it like i was in 1998.
you know i think the numbers and selling
tickets and everything got in the way of
what was just a hobby for me i got you
it was something that was supposed to be
fun
and now it wasn't fun anymore it gets
too much of a grind and when they sell
out and all this [__] they said
who the [__] no they they took this
money for this
you know what it was 10 years straight
i'm very happy about my accomplishments
i was not supposed to be here
i was supposed to go to prison and get
caught up in the prison system
some way god twisted that i'll take it
and i'll [__] leave and when i want
to come back
if it's a year if it's six months the
door is always open good for you
good hey did you see speak in a prison
system did you see
this [__] yesterday in oklahoma city
this prison riot in oklahoma city
no holy [__]
uh uh you yo they had these [__]
they took over the [__] prison they
had this guy
one of the the ceos they had them
[__] it was on video they had um
they had the [__] guy strung up they
were going nuts
and then apparently the cops came in
they shot one of the people and it was a
you got to see this look up oklahoma
city prison [__] it was michael
people that are free are going crazy
there's people that are not in prison
and mental health is at an all-time high
could you imagine just for two minutes
anybody who's listening to this podcast
or watching close your eyes
close your eyes let me and joey take you
into jail real quick and think of being
in prison think of being in prison and
right now and just
just think about the [__] talk walk
them through the cell joe
they're in the cell are we getting to
the cell walk them through listen they
probably gotta wear a mask if they got
another guy in the cell with them
and you you're in the cell with a guy
from oklahoma city
you know when he shits you smell it
and he you [__] he shit's good
you gotta smell that good [__] that he's
[__] how many prisoners aren't
getting money sent in because their
families are not working and they're
suffering in there
so now and listen they got to prison
[__] them
they made a mistake in life and now they
got to deal with it and i understand
that i was there when i was in prison
nobody [__] felt sorry for me
but i'm telling you right now that if
you think
people are going off and they're just
walking the streets
think of what inmates are going through
right they're probably not letting them
watch tv and
you know in a circle no more they
probably got to watch tv in their
[__] cells
god knows i don't know i don't know it's
been 30 years since i was in the [__]
prison cell thank god
but i can't imagine what it's like in
there
more prisoners should be [__] this is
not the first prison thing you're going
to hear about this year
you know so don't think this is you know
prison's got to be going crazy
but here's the funny thing here in new
jersey
every prisoner got vaccinated they got
vaccinated before school teachers
there are guys doing life in prison in
state prison here in rahway
and they got vaccinated before teachers
joey are you
[__] serious i'm being dead serious
for you not to pick a [__]
scab or anything but this is the reality
of this pandemic
these are the things that are happening
you cannot put your finger on it
all you could do every day is wake up
look at your computer and go god help me
before i open this computer
to see what the [__] i'm gonna read
today is it suzanne summers
having sex three times a day before
lunchtime
or is it [__] some [__] guy went
into a supermarket and shot 10 people
is it going to be a lady through [__]
what are we doing
like that you know what they're not even
pieces of [__]
it's mental health this is destroying
kids
oh i know i know kids that went from
having a's that are [__] not even
opening up the [__] computer and
it's not good this is you know we look
at each other i look at mike i look at
you
and i said i look at florentine i look
at these people and i go we don't really
know
what the struggle is right now yeah we
don't know what it is
what if right now you were living in l.a
you lost your job you're a decent person
and you're living in your car
there's a lot of guys like you and me
mike that were actors that are living in
their [__] cars right now
going to a place that lets them take a
shower once a day
go to all your parks this it's just not
listen when you look at the homeless
situation in l.a
50 of it is mental health bro yeah they
light their skin on fire
they do all that crazy [__] i'll tell
you what right now
in the next [__] year the number
from these eviction shits and all this
that people getting evicted
i read a story the other day here's the
best thing i read thursday
thursday or friday i read a family in
california
sold their house in riverside are you
ready for this
right they sold their house in riverside
the people paid for the house now they
refuse to leave the house
and they're protected through the
loophole through the eviction moratorium
so these people i heard about this did
you hear about this yeah these people
now
have to sue these people to move into a
house
that they paid for because there's a
loophole in the [__] system
that lets them stay in the house even
though the people paid them for the
[__] money
you paid them they paid the people that
are now
not leaving right and the people are
[__] going to stay in the [__]
house
and now the people that bought that
house are
[__] have to take them to court so
you made
my [__] day and i'm not again i'm not
one of those
you never heard me go i [__] hate
that later there's no bagels
the [__] pizza i was never one of
those new yorkers i was never one of
those new yorkers right the [__]
debate i missed the [__] bagels you
should stay off you should be happier
away from new york
fat [__] off the bagels and the pizza
and the doughnuts
no one wants to eat they got great
bagels in l.a they got they've got
everything
[__] neat out here they got nothing
yeah i've never been one of those guys
but i will tell you
that i did see the tide change
in people in la if you don't think when
if you don't think when lady gaga's dog
walker got shot that didn't bother me
i come from a place that nothing bothers
me like i don't give a [__]
why did it bother you because i walked
those streets
ah i walked those streets thousands of
times
i walked those streets i walked from you
know many times i walked from
schrader to the comedy store two in the
[__] morning
uh-huh how many times i walked up sierra
bonita to go to running i got in
i walked those streets i seemed to feel
that
somebody got shot walking a [__] dog
in la and they took three dogs
it breaks my heart yeah i'm hearing
things that are happening in the valley
i hear north hollywood goes off once it
gets dark
you know yo joe these [__]
the other night i'm not exaggerating
there was a chase in my neighborhood i
live in hancock
park which is it's a good neighborhood
very good neighborhood these [__]
were chasing this [__] for
five hours in my neighborhood up my
street down the street up la brea
detroit
finally this [__] he in a u-haul
five hours from one to six in the
morning i'm not exaggerating
helicopters over my house the [__]
house was
my wife said you slept through three and
a half hours of it because
i knew if i looked at my phone i would i
had to go to work in the morning
i i knew if i got up and looked at my
phone i was just like just go to sleep
just go to sleep just
go back to sleep this [__]
wouldn't come out of it you all he stole
a
five [__] hours of the [__]
helicopters and all this [__]
finally this prick comes out they
arrested this dumb [__]
i i don't need this in my life i gotta
get [__] sleep i gotta get up at
[__] six in the morning i'm shooting
a [__] show i
i i don't want you riding up and down my
street with the cops and the you
all i i don't who needs that [__]
i'm this is supposed to be like this
pristine place i don't need that
let me tell you something i haven't
i don't know how to put this i i'm like
being here for two weeks and looking at
my wife and going
i don't feel like henry hill no more i
don't hear helicopters every day
because every day i was hearing [__]
helicopters i felt like henry hill
everywhere i went there was a [__]
helicopter
i have not heard a helicopter in seven
or eight months mike i gotta be honest
with you you made my day by telling me
i don't want people
to leave la for the wrong reason right i
think
and for you i don't know where your head
is at i don't know if there's any doubt
or anything
brother you did everything there was to
do in l.a i come back
we're doing a podcast over zoom you're
in jersey i'm in l.a
these zoo i mean if they need me i got
work i come back i have no problem
coming back
who knows i might wind up getting in a
place in los angeles
i don't [__] know but i i don't need
to be here i need to be more in new york
than in la
and be because of my kids obviously
that's a big factor
but because they're older and and
because of all this this [__] with the
pandemic i'm like
i've done my [__] there's too much
technology like there's
you don't need to be here all the time i
don't want to be here all the time it
doesn't me i don't get anything from los
angeles
i don't get any not to say that new york
is perfect or jersey is perfect or
philly's perfect
or any of these other places are perfect
but la
it doesn't lend to me
like the biggest thing that i miss about
new york
is going out and finding the day
in new york you could go out and just
find the day you might stop in the park
you might stop here and get a slice
you might stop there get a coffee you
might run into your friend yo where you
going i'm going on the 23rd i'll walk
with you
oh okay cool uh you you know you oh i
meet up with my knife
my with my wife we'll go you know do
this we'll go shopping
just go the museum's up and we're going
to the [__] museum
and then at the end like six seven
o'clock you're like i had no idea what i
was gonna do but i found the [__]
thing
that's a perfect situation but i i just
driving everywhere the [__] that we
mentioned already
like we're we're um animals human beings
are animals
you're from a certain climate and a
certain you know habitat
we need to be in that habitat uh
to survive i prefer new york city
that's what i am manhattan that's where
i'm born and [__] raised
i prefer it i love it i adore it i know
the weather gets
[__] up what am i gonna do uh uh uh
it's fine so
i'm excited about it i'm happy about it
and so much good [__] happens when you
you change
obviously what we did is extreme and not
everybody could afford the luxury
of of of of making a change or being
able to change and all that stuff and
our lifestyles are different but
change is good it's scary but change is
[__] good
and so many things but we haven't even
gotten to new york just from the
the the changing it and the getting rid
of all the old [__] and the toothpaste
and the [__] geese
but but but aside from that so many
positive things have already happened
from this change that hasn't even uh
occurred yet so i'm i'm looking forward
to it i can't wait
why new york mike why didn't you choose
where i'm from
i'm born and raised in texas florida
[__] so many options
what am i going to do in texas maybe
maybe one day maybe i will get a place
in florida i don't know but
what the [__] am i going to do in texas
you know i know a lot of people went to
austin what am
i i've been to austin one time for three
days i don't know anything about austin
what am i gonna go there because a bunch
of comics are going there
joe rogan that's joe rogan you know
he's he's doing his [__] but i'm not i'm
50 [__] one years old
follow no man i'm married you know what
i mean what the [__] am i gonna do
for the young kids that's cool they
might think that's dope they don't have
families and all that [__]
but what the [__] am i gonna do in
[__] texas
oh they got bars there's our what the
i'm going
to new york city we got every [__]
thing
you're going everything every [__]
thing this is
you don't get any better so you're
austin there's some town
tulsa nashville i'm going to new york
the [__] are you going to tell me about
anything it's new york i don't care if
it's
cuomo de blasio crime's up crime's down
the [__] subway's working the
subway's not it's garbage
it's new york city it you're going home
brother
[__] manhattan that's where i'm from
you're going home no hey listen
i had options i thought about telly ride
i thought about boulder
i thought about austin and i knew
where i would be the happiest i wanted
my daughter
to see what i saw growing up right i am
ecstatic when my daughter says she wants
me to take a white castle
my [__] heart bleeds last night we
got home
at we got home last night at 10 to 9.
and i go mercy don't even [__] blink
go in the shower because we're gonna
miss the 9 30 honeymooners
every saturday we have a date we watch
the odd cup uh
archie bunker and then we watched the
honeymooners
you know she was ready to go my wife got
a second shot yesterday
so as soon as we got back she went right
to the [__] crib
i don't know how she's up and out today
she's doing she took it to the [__]
game zone i did this because it was time
to come home
gotta come home and you'll be back in
l.a ain't going anywhere
that job it's you know that i just uh
i got a little acting agent in new york
to start getting me little acting gigs
you know right uh
you're [__] joey cocodiaz if i don't
want to do them i don't do them if i
want to do them i do them
and uh i tell you you made my day
because
now i got somebody to visit when i go
over there [__]
see you we could go to an acting class
together we got a slice of pizza
together
yup whatever you just made my [__]
week man hey
i'm telling you when you called me it
was a saturday i think the fights were
on or before the fight i remember i was
and i was like oh [__] this [__]
[__] coco left and my wife was like
he [__] left i was like [__] coco
[__] left
and she was like we need to get the [__]
out of here i swear to god
i'm not bullshitting you i mean we were
already thinking about it but she was
like [__] we
it was just kind of like get the [__]
out
i did like i said it wasn't a comedy
thing for me
it was so listen i was coming no matter
what and the covet [__] it up
and they canceled the soprano shoot and
that stopped me from buying a house in
bergen county i was going to move to
bergen county
i ended up moving down to monmouth
county but i really wanted to go up
closer to where i was from but covert
had [__] that area up so i was like
[__] it
i'll just move down south and uh i'm
very happy i'm here
and i'm very happy that you're getting
the [__] out of there
and uh it's a tough decision if you have
any doubts i'm sure you don't you're a
strong [__] minded dude
and you're gonna do just great this is
yeah i'm looking forward to it
bro yo you've been watching the city
what'd you say
you were born you know uh what glenn fry
has that song you belong in the city
bro i heard it the other night on one of
the miami vice episodes it's on 11
o'clock here and i was like you know
what
this song hits in the head man you
belong to the city
and it's you got to come back at some
point and i love
new yorkers i've always loved new
yorkers and new yorkers love
me i [__] adore new yorkers i
and and there's not as many as there
used to be but i love
[__] that are from the five
[__] boroughs
and we don't even i run into mother you
get the same thing because
we have the same sort of people that uh
uh
you know in in the east coast that that
that [__] with you
they talk i'm like a lot of times i'm
like do i know this [__] guy because
they're just like mike rap what's up did
you watch the game last night and i'm
like
do i know i'm talking to the guy and
then i'm like i don't even know the [__]
i'm talking to but
new yorkers know a new yorker and i know
a new yorker and i just
i love walking the streets of new york i
don't give a [__] if it's hot
cold snowing raining i get honked at
i get [__] uh people screaming at me
from a cross street mic
rap it's my father's there he's 87
he hasn't gotten covered he [__] colt
joey my father
[__] covert in the [__] he [__]
covert right up the ass he's 87.
he's a jewish dinosaur he bent coven
over
and bang covered right up the ass he's
good and what about moms
great too mark and joanne gray
everybody's
and we're been lucky so far well man i
will be here waiting for you
you made my [__] week by telling me
you're coming here in may
it's hard to believe that you're leaving
la but you s that's it you did what you
had to do man
and five [__] and you made it happen
i'm [__] i love you mike you know
love you too
i'm happy i'm happy you made time for me
today of course
and uh happy passover to you and your
family thank you
and uh we'll talk when you [__] get
to l.a please any time
joe i'm as soon as you hit new york just
give me a call i don't
i got you you're gonna be busy for three
months unpacking
get trust me these mothers but i got rid
of a lot of [__] though
i got i was in two [__] bags full
this morning at
at the uh at the the goodwill [__] they
know me they say what's up how you doing
mike moore stuff
yup two bags was the least of mine and
even the big
black [__] garbage bag the big
[__] not the little not the little [__]
you use in the kitchen i'm talking about
the [__]
like you could put a hefty hefty hefty
20 of those books
i was taking clothes karate clothes to
different schools
i had protein powders i had [__]
watches i had so much [__]
but listen thank you for coming on the
joint i love you anything you need
you know you can find me hopefully when
you move i can get on your podcast and
just go
for sure and we'll do a [__] studio
gig or something for sure
thank you for coming on the journey love
you coco coco [__] diaz
stay black [__] i love you i'll
talk to you soon power
happy passover all right
what'd you think [__] right when
two old friends get together it's just a
conversation
it's not a podcast no more this is what
him and i would be saying to each other
on the phone
uh i feel happy that he's leaving you
know
not because of uh you know
i think la crime went up 61 percent
i know that they cut a million dollars
from their budget and now they had to
put another 40 million in because uh
they're expecting a heavy-duty [__]
summer of uh
marches and whatever the [__] they call
them peaceful parades and gatherings
but i think it was you know people
changed i mean that was a
he's a hardcore actor he has a lot but
way better credits than i do and
it's time to change and i called this in
march that people are going to look at
their lives and go what the [__] am i
doing here
for him it was seeing some homeless lady
throw a piece of [__]
that's what i've always said once
somebody throws a piece of [__] it's
time to [__] pack up your bags and
[__] leave
and with that i will leave you until
next [__] monday i hope you enjoyed
the podcast this week
i hope you're enjoying what i'm doing i
hope you enjoy the growth it hasn't just
been me
mike has been [__] 90 of this with
the sound and the lights and
we're really [__] trying for you guys
to put something together what we got we
didn't have all the tools when we
started
and we could give you i still remember
we did the rich boss podcast and they
were [__] hot at us and [__]
and i loved it because uh it just goes
to show you
that you gotta try things if not you're
never gonna know where they're gonna go
you gotta try and sometimes you fall on
your ass and sometimes you do good but
you're never gonna know that you try
i love your [__] thank you for
listening and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for listening
i want to thank michael rappaport i want
to thank you guys
i also want to thank life for being
beautiful but
before we get the hell out of here i
want to talk to you about something
listen
uh for years i didn't sleep when i got
up to 418 pounds
i was sleeping maybe four hours a night
you could jump up and down you could do
all the exercise and you can
but if you don't sleep properly and get
deep rem sleep
it's not gonna work out for you that's
why i love blue blocks
blue blocks makes the best leap mass
known to man
they sent them to me a couple weeks ago
i took a look at i go what the hell let
me give it a shot
let me tell you something the first
night i slept like a baby i got a sleep
apnea mascot
this fits right over the mask i look
like a pilot to bombardier i was finally
pilot the bombardier
so if you're having a hard time sleeping
because you have any light in the room
get rid of the light because any amount
of light will keep you up
go with blue block sleep mask because it
blocks out
everything total darkness once you go
black you'll never sleep with anything
else
listen the thing i like about it the
most is it cups your eyes and it makes
the world go away
it helps you drift off to sleep i put my
pair on i hit the bed
i sang our father i say hell marry and i
go what is that going to do for me
and next thing you know it clears my
mind and i fall asleep why
because i just it just drips away the
adjustable head strap won't wear out
and it's contoured sides alive for side
and belly sleepers
there's going to be no slipping involved
when i wake up in the morning i wake up
the total darkness and i remember what
the
i wake up like what the hell is going oh
that's right i got my sleep goggles on
let me take them off remedy made a great
sleep mask they really hit it out of the
park it's comfortable
it doesn't squeeze your face like a
grape plus it's made with lightweight
breathable fabric to keep you cool
all night long they thought of
everything i applaud them
i love it my daughter my my
eight-year-old daughter
wears these things she puts on a car map
and then she puts these on i go in there
to kiss her and i'm like who am i
kissing
who are you the pilot from from never
say die so do me a favor right now
support blue blocks right now get yours
today get 20
off with code joey at blue blocks b l
u b o o x dot com
slash joey that's blue blocks
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com
slash joey for 20 off blue blocks
dot-com slash joey use promo code
joey what else can i tell you night
night [__]
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter listen to me whether you got
four employees
or 500 employees you don't have time to
go through a bunch of resumes right now
there's a lot going on
you know you're trying to find the right
person you need somebody to wear a lot
of hats
listen finding that person is hard it's
like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
it ends today why because i'm gonna let
you try ziprecruiter.com
joey for free free free
even if you have a simple position to
fill that takes forever to find the
great fit
that's over that's where zip recruiter
comes in and it's
fine it's a qualified candidates fast
whether you're looking to hire a
a cook in in nebraska
a mascot a missouri you know
a doctor in arkansas zip recruiters
matching technology will hook you up
with the people who have the skills and
experience that you're looking to get
and then it actively invites them to
apply for the job
get quality candidates fast in fact zip
recruit is so effective
that four to five employees who post on
zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day from accounting to zoologists
and everything in between ziprecruiter
makes hiring that much
easier so right now just for the for the
joint listeners you can try
ziprecruiter for free free free free
that's right
zip recruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com
joey that ziprecruiter.com joey try it
for free
i get credit by sending you there and
it's a great product and you're gonna
enjoy it
you're gonna need it why time and energy
and effort to get the best that's out
there that's the zip recruiter it has to
offer you
so go to ziprecruiter.com joey
and give it a zip for free zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
i want to thank zip recruiter i want to
thank
blue blocks i want to thank draftkings
do not forget this weekend
they're running major specials i think
it's down to eight teams four teams the
final four
you cannot miss out on this you [__]
up last week
now don't do it again this week go to
draftkings
download the app and press preston joey
i want to thank cbd
lion i want to thank honor anybody who's
got my back i got your back
but most importantly i want to thank the
people who watched the show who stuck it
out with us
we've had some burps and some bumps but
[__] that
we're going for it i love you
[__] have a great week
i'll see you monday it'll be april 6th
the 5th
and we'll be taking another [__]
month down you understand me
i love you [__] have a great
weekend stay black
here you go the candle is unlit
[__]
[Music]
so
you